this is game tech where we break down
the tech that drives the games we love
and personally I love keyboard and mouse
controls and shooters and while I'm
primarily a PC gamer I spend a lot of
time on my ps4 as well which is why I
was hyped up to get my hands on Horry
stacked achill assault commander or TAC
pro a plug-and-play keypad and mouse
combo that emulates a PC controls for
the ps4 I figured I then have an
advantage over other players in PvP and
carry the team in PvE during the destiny
to beta however the limitations of the
TAC pro left my performance inconsistent
at best the keypad itself is wonderfully
designed its near-perfect placement of
all the DualShock 4 controls make it
easy to use straight out of the box
square which is typically the reload
action in games is where our would be on
the keyboard circle typically crouching
is in the control keys place and l3 for
sprinting is in shifts place triangle
which is commonly used for weapon
switching is in the Q keys place and
obviously the movement Keys work just
like WASD X which is commonly used for
the jump action is right where your
thumb is just like having a spacebar a
joystick also resides near the thumb
area which can be used for movement just
like the controller's left stick if you
prefer but it can also act as the d-pad
almost everything you find on a
DualShock 4 is here the touchpad the
home button and the options and share
buttons the packaged Mouse fits nicely
into the hand
clicking felt right and the two side
buttons were great for melee actions and
grenade throws a dpi switch lets you
swap between three sensitivity settings
on the fly the mouse cord is real short
but it's long enough to plug into the
keypad the keypad then plugs into the
ps4 and the TAC pro is pretty much ready
to go so while the keypad and the mouse
have essential features aiming with the
mouse is where the TAC pro falls short
in consistent tracking and sensitivity
of mouse movement negates the key
advantage of having a mouse precise
aiming you won't get one-to-one tracking
in games so coming from a shooter on the
PC to the tech brawl on the ps4 aiming
felt extremely awkward you can adjust
the mouse acceleration on the TAC pro
but there wasn't any setting that came
close to true mouse movement with
acceleration at its lowest setting
possible swiping the mouse across the
mouse
actually showed some deceleration that's
on top of the straight-up
inconsistent sensitivity between picking
up and quickly swiping the mouse and
moving the mouse across slowly the
cursor moved at different speeds this
frequent change of sensitivity also
extends to aiming-down-sights and made
things even more difficult destiny too
has generous auto aiming adding to the
awkward feel of the mouse it's all so
strange because auto aim is necessary to
be competent in the game given the
unstable tracking now we tinker with
several in-game sensitivity settings
acceleration modes on the tach pearl and
different dpi settings on the mouse but
no combination of these settings resolve
the erratic tracking with that said
there are moments where I felt more in
control and accurately anticipated the
mouse behavior I could land consecutive
shots with the Sun shot hand cannon at
times I could also move from one target
to another in a snappy fashion with the
skate lock auto rifle helpful for taking
down those damned harpies during the
final boss battle in the strike but
being able to do this banked on my
ability to predict how the mouse would
track with my hand movement and the
reality is that we shouldn't have to
worry about consistent sensitivity when
playing in a competitive crucible match
let alone a PvE strike mission the point
of having mouse and keyboard controls on
a console is to get the same precision
of PC gaming when I went back to playing
on a dual shot I kind of missed having
the feel of a keypad and mouse and sort
of lamented sniping with an analog stick
but I'm much preferred playing destiny 2
on the ps4 with a controller it's hard
to recommend the Hori tech pro based on
my experience and especially at 150
bucks
you're better off investing in a pro
grade controller if you're looking for
an advantage in console games speaking
of aftermarket controllers check out our
roundup of the best ps4 controllers to
help up your game and subscribe to our
channel here at GameSpot to keep up with
game tech give this video a like and
we'll see you next time thanks for
watching